YOU WANT TO PUT THAT
IN YOUR MOUTH?
- MM-HMM.
- WHAT DID I JUST
PUT IN MY MOUTH?
- THAT WAS CANTALOUPE.
- I LIKE CANTALOUPE.
- OKAY.
THIS IS PINEAPPLE.
DO YOU LIKE PINEAPPLE?
- I LIKE PINEAPPLE.
FOR TEN EPISODES
OF THE SUPERMAN RADIO SHOW,
SUPERMAN FOUGHT THE KKK.
UP IN THE SKY,
IT'S A BIRD, IT'S A PLANE.
NO, IT'S SUPERMAN!
SUPERMAN,
BATTLING VALIANTLY
AGAINST THE CLAN
OF THE FIERY CROSS.
JIMMY OLSEN, PROTECTED
BY THE POWER OF SUPERMAN
AND HIS MIGHTY MIGHT.
I DON'T [bleep]ING KNOW.
- [laughs]
- CAREFUL, JIMMY,
DON'T TOUCH THAT FIERY CROSS.
AH, SHUCKS, MR. KENT,
WHATEVER YOU SAY.
THERE WAS NO YOUTUBE,
THERE WAS NO PODCASTS.
EVERYBODY
LISTENED TO THE RADIO.
AS THIS WAS HAPPENING,
STETSON KENNEDY
WOULD CALL THEM AND SAY,
HERE ARE THE NEW PASSWORDS THAT
THE KKK ARE USING THIS WEEK.
THE CODEWORD WAS "ANGLO."
THE PASSWORD
WAS "AMERICAN."
THE NEXT WEEK,
ON THE SUPERMAN SHOW,
SUPERMAN WOULD SHOW UP
AND SAY, "ANGLO."
AND ONE OF THE BAD GUYS
WOULD RESPOND WITH, "AMERICAN."
THE KIDS OF THE KLANSMEN
WERE PLAYING SUPERMAN
AGAINST THE KKK.
FOLLOWING THE BROADCAST
OF THE SUPERMAN EPISODES,
ONE OF THE HEADS OF THE KLAVERN
SAID TO THE LEADER,
SIR, I CANNOT,
IN GOOD CONSCIENCE,
CONTINUE AS A MEMBER
OF THIS KLAVERN
WHEN MY OWN CHILDREN
ARE POKING FUN
AT THE CLAN
OF THE FIERY CROSS.
[sneezes]
[coughs]
- BLESS YOU.
- THANK YOU.
[sneezes]